Prof: We're now going to
start the block of the course
which is on ecology,
and these are the titles of the
upcoming lectures.
You can think of ecology as
providing the theater in which
the evolutionary play occurs;
that's a metaphor from Evelyn
Hutchinson.
And basically I'm doing a
top-down, and then going back;
going from the top down,
and then going from the bottom
back up to the top,
in going through these
lectures.
So I'm going to start today by
taking about climate and the
planet,
and how life is distributed on
the planet,
and then move from that into
the biology.
So looking at physiological
ecology and interactions with
the physical environment,
leading from that through
population growth,
competition,
predation, parasitism,
up to community--so that's sort
of a way of doing a Cartesian
bottom up construction of
communities--
and then dealing with some of
the larger scale issues in
ecology,
which have to do with islands
and meta-populations,
and then systems ecology,
energy and matter flow.
And then I'm going to end with
a lecture which is both about
the role of biodiversity in
ecology,
but also about general takes on
the value of biodiversity,
and this last lecture in
ecology is going to include some
stuff like an economic take on
biodiversity,
an evolutionary take on
as well as the issue of does
biodiversity actually help
ecosystems to function better?
So that's what's coming up.
And today we're going to
basically look at the climates
of the planet,
how the planet can be looked at
as a set of climate machines,
and how they generate the
biomes, on the planet.
So at this scale,
this stuff I think is probably
pretty familiar.
The world climate is of course
cold at the poles and warm at
the tropics, but there's a lot
of detail in that.
It tends to be warmer and
wetter on the western sides of
the northern continents,
and cooler and drier on the
eastern sides of the northern
continents.
The influence of the Gulf
Stream can be seen pretty
clearly here in Europe,
with this large warm area being
sort of pushed up and to the
right by the warm water,
which is coming up out of the
Gulf of Mexico.
And if you go far east into the
huge block of the Eurasian land
mass,
you can get so far away from
the effects of the ocean that
the coldest temperature,
at least in the Northern
Hemisphere,
was recorded right about here.
It was, I think,
-127 Fahrenheit;
which, you know, that's nippy.
There are interesting
similarities in the climates of
similar places.
So if you look at the western
leading edge of North and South
America,
and you go about as far south
of the equator as north,
basically what you run into is
a temperate rainforest.
There's a temperate rainforest
that is stretching from Northern
California up to Alaska,
and there's another temperate
rainforest which stretches along
the coast of Chile.
And these similarities in
climate have created similar
biomes and similar selection
pressures,
and have led to convergences in
the communities that you see in
these places.
So if you really want to
understand why is it that if I
am standing say in Chile,
or in part of New Zealand,
or in British Columbia,
that they kind of remind me of
each other?
Even though the plants may not
be at all related,
they look the same,
it feels the same,
the forests have similar
structure.
Well you have to go back to why
the planet as a whole constructs
similar climates in those
places.
Part of it, at a local level,
if you're looking say at what's
generating the rainforest in
Chile or what's generating the
rainforest in British Columbia,
has to do with the way that
mountains are interacting with
atmosphere.
So in both, in these
situations, you have got clouds
that are coming in off of the
ocean, and they are being forced
upward by a mountain range.
And there's some very simple
physical chemistry that goes on
when you force a cloud upward.
The rising air is going to be
cooling before it condenses.
Then it will condense and form
heavy clouds,
and they will rain out,
and as the wind is going to
push them up over the top of the
mountain range,
basically all the water will
leave the cloud.
Well that's what's creating
that rainforest.
Okay?
And the reason for that is that
cold air can't hold as much
water as warm air.
And the cooling is going on at
a rate of about 6 degrees
Centigrade per kilometer of
elevation, going up.
The air which was at 20,
coming in off the ocean--
this is 20 degrees
Centigrade--is hitting perhaps 4
degrees at the top of the
mountain--
so you could think of this as
the Sierras,
or the top of say the Cascades
in Oregon or Washington--
and then it falls down the
other side.
And over here you have dry air
falling.
This is wet air rising,
and it rains out,
and then you have dry air
falling.
And this wet air rising and
raining,
and dry air falling and
warming, and ending up 4 degrees
warmer at the same elevation on
this side than it was on this
side,
because of the heat of
condensation that's been
released by the rain here.
This is something I want you to
remember,
because it actually also
applies at the scale of the
whole planet,
when you have very large air
cells that are rotating on the
planet.
And where there's dry air
falling, you're going to get
deserts,
and where there is warm air
rising you're going to get
rainforests,
whether you have the mountain
range there or not.
So we'll see that in a minute,
and that's why I wanted to
introduce this level of analysis
at this point.
Okay?
So this warm air falling here
is called foehn in Switzerland,
and the Swiss always complain
that it gives them headaches;
it's called the Santa Ana wind
in Los Angeles;
and there's a special wind that
blows down the valley behind
Lahaina, Maui,
that can hit 140 miles an hour
sometimes, which is similar.
So these local dry hot winds
can be very important,
and they're actually what drive
the wild fires in Malibu and
things like that.
Okay, now let's take a look at
the whole planet.
If the earth was simply a
stationary ball,
sitting in space,
undisturbed,
but was being heated at the
equator,
it would develop basically two
convection cells,
one in each hemisphere.
So there would be cold air that
was falling on the poles.
It would be falling down to the
surface and it would be picking
up moisture and rising,
and basically you would get a
belt of rainforest around the
equator,
and you would have deserts at
the poles and a gradient in
between.
That would be what would happen
if the earth were not rotating.
The earth is rotating,
and because it's rotating,
on an idealized planet you
would get three Hadley cells,
going out from the
equator--three in the north and
three in the south--
and at the equator you would
have warm air rising and it
would be dropping rain,
because as it rose it cooled,
and it would lose capacity to
hold water and it would rain
out.
Then it would flow northward
and fall at about 30º
north.
Okay?
There it would be interacting
with another similar cell that
would be carrying warm air north
and rising at about 60 north.
Okay?
Remember where the rainforests
were in Chile and in British
Columbia;
they are in this region here
and in this region here.
And this is where the deserts
are, around the world;
they're at about 30 North and
30 South.
Now this is an idealized format.
At the boundary,
by the way, of where you've got
the polar highs and the northern
Hadley cell here,
right at this boundary is where
you get a polar front,
and this is where the jet
stream goes around the world in
the north and it goes around the
world in the south.
So the location of the jet
stream that drives most of the
weather that we encounter here,
and the idea that it might say
pull in a mass of Canadian- a
clipper of Canadian weather
coming in from the polar front
here,
is actually generated by this
structure,
and it's wobbly.
Okay?
In an idealized world this is
all smooth, and these lines are
clean and whatnot.
But, in fact,
the surface of the planet has
got stuff on it,
like continents and oceans,
and as this stuff moves in its
circulation pattern,
both north and south,
and west to east,
around the Northern Hemisphere,
it wobbles,
because it's been deflected by
local perturbations like
mountain ranges and oceans.
So out of this you get patterns
of wind that in fact have--well
now but they not only currently
generate weather.
You can really only understand
say the history of the last 8 or
10,000 years of human
civilization on the planet by
realizing that the people who
were trading,
and were using boats to move,
were relying on the fact that
at about 35,
40º north,
you can count on a west wind;
at about 20º
north you can count on a trade
wind;
and that repeats in the
Southern Hemisphere.
And this is actually--these
trades here, over in the Indian
Ocean, were what drove the trade
between India and the Roman
Empire;
things like that.
So you should think of the
planet as being covered
with--these are really very thin
sheets.
When you think,
for example,
that we're looking here
probably at 3 or 4000 miles,
4 or 5000 kilometers,
and the depth of this cell is
actually only about 5 to 10
kilometers.
So it's a very thin cell,
which is rotating like that.
Now if there weren't any
continents, you'd end up with
something that looked like
Jupiter.
Okay, Jupiter has these nice
neat bands that go around,
and it is a bit--it's not the
perfect,
smooth Hadley cell picture that
I was showing you,
but still that's quite a tight
band there.
And these are rotating cells.
Jupiter's bigger.
It's got a few more of them
than the earth does.
The earth, by the way,
sitting on this picture is--oh,
it's about that big.
>
So this is a lot bigger.
Because the earth has the
continents and the oceans,
you don't get that smooth
picture in a shot from space,
looking at the clouds.
You see a lot of swirls and
vortexes that are being caused
by these local perturbations.
Right here you've got the
African continent coming down;
you've got Antarctica down here.
This is 40 to 60 south;
clear ocean all the way around
the planet;
winds blowing in this direction;
they can go all the way around
the planet with unobstructed
ocean, just about the whole way,
except maybe just from the tip
of South America.
This is where you can get open
ocean waves that are up to 100
feet, 30 meters high.
And, of course,
this is also where the
Whitbread Round the World race
goes down,
so that people can go really
fast around the globe and take
their life in their hands in
pretty rough weather.
So the earth doesn't really
have the idealized model of
climate that I've shown you in
the previous pictures.
It's more chaotic,
but there's still a pattern
there;
and I want to emphasize now
some of the patterns.
So, of course,
heat's being moved.
Basically what's going on is
that heat's being moved from the
equator,
towards the poles,
simply by physical chemical
forces,
to try to equalize the heat
gradient that's coming in from
the sun,
and that's done by wind and by
water.
Now as a packet of air or water
moves towards the poles,
it's coming with higher radio
velocity.
Just think about the difference
in the diameter of the spinning
earth at the equator and at the
poles.
At the equator the diameter of
the planet is roughly 8000
miles;
so the radius is about 4000
miles.
And as you move a packet of air
or water up towards the pole,
by the time it gets to the
pole, the diameter is 0.
Okay?
So in between--basically it's a
trigonometric function that's
telling you what's the diameter
of the spinning object as I go
north.
So if I'm coming from the
equator, and I'm headed north,
I have more angular momentum
than the ground under my feet
that I'm moving onto.
It's moving slower to the east
than I am moving.
And if I'm standing at the
poles and I start going south,
the ground under my feet is
staring to move out from under
me,
because I don't have as much
angular momentum.
So what that will do is it will
take a packet of air or water
that moves toward the equator,
it's coming down with lower
radial velocity,
and it will be accelerated to
the west.
That apparent force--and by the
way, so going north you'll be
accelerated eastward;
coming south you'll be
accelerated westward,
in the Northern Hemisphere.
This is an apparent force.
Okay?
It's called the Coriolis force,
and it's shaping the direction
of major ocean currents,
and it's also shaping things
like the trade winds;
and you'll see in a minute that
it shapes the way that
hurricanes spin.
So I'd like you to take just--I
want to make sure that you get
this, and I'm going to ask,
in a minute,
if one of you can explain it.
Okay?
So can you just take a minute
and explain it to your partner,
how the Coriolis force works,
and what's really going on
here.
It's a piece of
three-dimensional geometry,
and basically it's driven by
the fact that the earth is
spinning on its axis and things
are moving north and south on
the surface of this ball.
Okay?
One or two minutes.
<<Students confer with
one another>>
<<Professor interacts
with one student>>
Prof: Do you want to
explain it to me?
Student:  I need a
picture;
I'm not very good with the
words here.
Prof: Come on.
So here's a packet moving north.
Student:  Okay.
Prof: Let's take a slice
through the equator here,
and what you'd see inside here
is a circle,
that has a radius of 4000
miles, and if I do a slice up
here,
it has a radius of say 2000
miles.
Student:  Right.
Prof: Okay?
So in 24 hours,
this thing is spinning very
rapidly;
it's got 1000 miles an hour
angular velocity,
down here.
Right?
Up here it has--let's see,
this is 4 times 3 1/2;
instead of 24,000 miles
diameter, this is about 12,000
miles diameter.
So it's only got 500 miles
angular velocity,
up here.
So this is coming with 1000
miles angular velocity,
up into an area where the
ground under its feet is moving
500 miles per hour slower.
So it's going to go like this.
Student:  Ah.
Prof: Got it?
Student:  Yeah,
it helped.
Prof: Does the picture
help?
Student:  Yes it does.
<<Professor addresses the
class>>
Prof: Okay,
I just learned that the picture
is helpful.
Okay, I'm going to do the
picture again for you.
Actually maybe one of you can
come up and help me do it.
Anybody want to help me?
Anybody feeling brave this
morning, bold,
life threatening?
Get up at the board with the
professor.
Okay, here's the planet.
Here's the north/south axis of
the planet.
Here's the equator.
The circumference of the earth
at the equator is about 24,000
miles,
and the earth is turning around
once per day,
which means that a packet of
air or water,
which is sitting at the
equator, is moving east at about
1000 miles per hour.
We're going to ship it north.
Okay?
It's going to be carrying heat
toward the pole.
We choose a convenient spot to
take another slice of the earth
where the circumference of the
earth is 12,000 miles.
This chunk of ground is moving
at 500 miles per hour.
So as this pack of air goes
north, the ground underneath it,
by the time it's gotten up
here, is going 500 miles per
hour,
towards the east,
slower than it is.
So what it does is it overtakes
the ground that's underneath it,
and it bends to the east.
Okay?
And you can just play that back
and forth in your head.
You can go from the north to
the south.
You can do it in the Southern
Hemisphere;
it'll work in the other
direction.
Any questions on that?
In order to see it,
you actually have to break the
motion of the planet down,
in your head,
and put yourself in the shoes
of something which is moving
north or south,
and essentially what happens is
at the ground you either exceed
the speed of the ground
underneath you,
or the ground goes out from
under your feet,
if you're going south.
So that's basically the
Coriolis force.
I once had to explain this in
German,
and I was just learning German,
and instead of saying "the
earth spins",
which is okay in English,
I said, "die Erde
spinnt" in German,
which means that the world is
crazy.
They loved it.
It was totally wrong,
but they loved it.
Okay, the result of this is
that if these motions--
you know, so here you've got
the Coriolis Force taking the
Kuroshio Current and bending it
to the east,
as it goes north,
and then when it comes down the
West Coast as the California
Current,
it gets bent to the west,
and in each of the hemispheres
you establish a rotation in the
ocean that looks like this.
Here in the south you have
water which is flowing north;
it's getting bent to the west.
You've got water flowing to the
south, it's getting bent to the
east.
So you get counter-clockwise in
the Southern Hemisphere and
clockwise in the Northern
Hemisphere.
Now on top of this,
just as I showed you for the
Hadley cells in the atmosphere,
there's an important
three-dimensional cell structure
in the oceans.
So north of the Antarctic
continent there's a place where
the cold surface water of the
Antarctic gets- sinks,
at the Antarctic
convergence--it's down about
here--
and it then forms a cell which
creeps along the floors of the
major oceans and then comes back
up.
There's a very important spot
where water from the Arctic
Ocean, coming down from
Greenland, is sinking near the
Gulf Stream here.
And it's one of the real
current issues in global warming
as to whether or not this point
up here or this--
actually it's not a point--this
whole sheet of sinking water is
going to remain stable.
Because if it doesn't remain
stable,
and this moves south,
then the Gulf Stream will get
blocked and basically England,
France and Spain are going to
end up with a climate which is
like that of Northern Canada;
very quickly.
That is something that could
happen in a couple of years,
if this thing tips.
So understanding that kind of
movement actually has big
implications,
for society and for the people
who live in these places,
who are in the hundreds of
millions.
Now there are just--I want to
show you two things about the
general pattern.
This is just repeating the
overall pattern on the planet.
We get hurricanes roughly where
there are trade winds,
and we get them both in the
Northern and in the Southern
Hemisphere.
And then right at the equator
we get El Niño,
in the Pacific.
And I want to show you a little
bit about hurricanes and a
little bit about El Niño,
because those are two of the
sort of large-scale weather
patterns that occur on the
planet.
So this question here:
Why do cyclones turn
counter-clockwise in the
Northern Hemisphere and
clockwise in the Southern,
is a bit puzzling,
because I have just shown you
that if you take a packet of air
or water and you ship it north,
it's going to result in a
clockwise circulation in the
north and a counter-clockwise
circulation in the south.
And yet here is a nice photo
from space of Hurricane Katrina
starting to go over Florida,
before it hits New Orleans;
Cyclone Larry,
equally destructive,
plowing into Northern
Australia.
And you can see quite clearly
that Hurricane Katrina is
counter-clockwise and Cyclone
Larry is clockwise.
And that looks puzzling,
but here's the answer.
If you take a standard packet
of air,
moving south in the Northern
Hemisphere,
hitting something like
Hurricane Katrina,
it will come down and it will
take this low,
and it will spin it.
And if you have this as a set
of clockwise forces,
operating on a low,
they will spin it
counter-clockwise.
And the same thing operating in
the Southern Hemisphere will
spin a cyclone in the Southern
Hemisphere into a clockwise
shape.
So really it's an interesting
problem of figure and ground,
or just what perspective are
you standing in,
when you're trying to figure
out why the thing is spinning
that way.
Because basically it is being
operated on by external Coriolis
forces that are generating the
antagonistic movement,
the unexpected movement in the
structure,
but it results in very
important consequences for
anybody that's in the path of
one of these things.
So that's basically the
explanation of why we see a
counter-intuitive kind of spin
on these big storms.
Now about El Niño.
I think El Niño actually
is an extremely interesting and
neat phenomenon.
It has huge implications,
and it drives weather patterns
in fact over much of the planet;
not just at the equator.
Under normal conditions
basically what's going on is
that you have these,
the Kuroshio Current in the
northern Pacific,
which is coming down off of
California and Mexico,
and then going west along the
equator.
You've got the Humboldt Current
in the southern Pacific,
which is coming north,
along the coast of Chile and
Peru,
and then curving out to the
west, driven in those big
clockwise Northern Hemisphere
gyres and counter-clockwise
Southern Hemisphere gyres.
And what they're doing--because
they have a continent more or
less to the right here--
they are picking up the water
and shoving it offshore,
and that's causing the lower
bottom water to well up,
and they are shoving the warm
surface water out to the west.
And that causes a big buildup
of warm water,
which is out about at Guam in
the Marianas,
so--or all the way to the
Philippines.
And this pile of warm water is
actually about a meter higher
than the water in the eastern
Pacific,
and it's being held there by
the currents and the winds.
So it's actually,
over a distance of about 7 or
8000 miles,
it's picking the surface of the
ocean up and it's stacking it up
a meter higher,
out to the west, in the Pacific.
Now under El Niño
conditions,
what happens is that the
currents break down,
and when the currents break
down, the force that was holding
the water higher in the western
Pacific goes away.
And what does the water do?
It falls downhill,
it flows back to the eastern
Pacific, covering the eastern
Pacific up with a layer of hot
water.
This has all kinds of
consequences.
One of the consequences is that
warm water evaporates more than
cold water,
and so rainfall increases,
in the eastern Pacific,
and cells that carry a lot of
water will then get blown into
places like Mexico and Arizona.
And during El Niño
conditions you'll get much
heavier rainfall in the American
West,
and all the way through to the
Mississippi Valley,
than you will during normal
conditions.
But another very important
thing happens.
This covers up the upwelling.
It covers up the cold water
that was coming up from the
bottom of the ocean,
and that cold water that was
coming up from the bottom of the
ocean is carrying with it all
kinds of fertilizer.
Basically the bottom of the
ocean has been receiving the
dead bodies of algae and
zooplankton and everything else
for a long time.
There's been a lot of nitrogen
and phosphate building up down
there, and under normal
conditions that's being carried
up by the upwelling.
And when El Niño rolls
in, it covers it up,
turns off the fertilization
process.
The alga production goes down,
zooplankton production goes
down, the fish don't have so
much to eat and the fishery
stocks collapse.
So once every ten or eleven
years,
when this happens,
the great fisheries of the
Eastern Pacific collapse,
and that means that thousands
of fishermen go out of work;
it means that sea birds starve.
And you should think of the
whole Pacific Ocean as kind of
ringing like a bell on about a
ten or eleven year interval.
And since the Pacific Ocean
occupies roughly half the
planet,
that means there are signatures
of this that reverberate all the
way around the planet,
on about a ten year interval.
When I was doing my Ph.D.
on the evolution of mosquito
fish in Hawaii,
I had sixty years of records of
the level of sugar plantation
reservoirs in Hawaii,
and I did a time series
analysis on it and I picked up
two very dominant signals.
There was a short frequency
signal, which was the
weekends--that's when people
went home on the weekends;
so the reservoirs didn't
fluctuate on the weekends.
But there was an eleven-year
signal that was El Niño,
and it was the biggest,
strongest signal in the data.
So up in Hawaii,
which is really quite a ways
away--
on this map,
Hawaii would be up off the map,
up here somewhere--this is
making a big impact on the
ten-year rainfall record,
and it's doing so in Arizona
and New Mexico and Texas,
and California as well.
Okay, so that's El Niño.
And to see what it looks like.
This is a NOA picture of the
temperature of the Pacific,
going from the eastern Pacific
out to the western Pacific.
And these are different years.
So this is starting in 1986 and
going up to 2001,
and this year,
right here, where you see a big
tongue of warm water,
29º Centigrade,
pushing all the way back in to
the eastern Pacific is 1997;
one of the major El Niño
events.
And, in fact,
there is right now,
I think in the last year or so,
another El Niño event.
Yes, Myra?
Student:
>
Prof: There appears to
have been this kind of cyclicity
in the Pacific for as long back
as we can see in the records.
I think that the things that
would probably make it break
down are plate tectonic events.
I do not know if El Niño
was regular before the Isthmus
of Panama formed about ten
million years ago.
I suspect it would've been
different.
And this is just that--this is
the actual temperature,
and then this is the deviation
from the normal.
And, by the way,
they call a year that's sort of
really super normal,
La Niña.
So this is a La Niña and
this is El Niño,
down here.
So you should think of La
Niña as being cold water
in the eastern Pacific,
and El Niño as being hot
water in the eastern Pacific,
with all of its consequences.
In La Niña you've got
the upwelling going,
and in El Niño it's
interrupted;
and of course that would be
happening basically right along
here.
But upwelling is normal in much
of the planet,
and it happens along coastal
margins.
So the areas here that are
indicated in red is where cold,
deep water is being moved to
the surface by various forces,
and in the process is
fertilizing the surface layer,
and that's driving the
productivity of the world's
oceans.
So people, of course,
have discovered this;
I mean, one could have made a
theoretical argument,
but in fact the world's
fishermen discovered this long
before there was any climatic
theory.
And the greatest productivity
in the world's oceans are in
places like the North Sea,
the Benguela Current,
and the West Coast of Africa;
the coast of Peru with its
gigantic anchovy fishery;
West Coast of North America
with tuna and sardines and
things like that;
and you can see a few other
spots around the world that are
very productive.
Fishing is mighty good in New
Zealand.
The way this works is through a
combination of offshore winds
and the Coriolis force.
So let's first do the offshore
wind.
If you have any body of land,
and you have wind blowing
offshore,
it pushes the surface water
off, and just in order for
gravity to equilibrate the water
pressure,
it's going to therefore pull up
deep water at the shore line.
And if any of you live on the
West Coast,
I think you know this perfectly
well,
because you know that very
often the water on the shoreline
of the West Coast is colder than
the air,
and it is going to produce fog.
And all the way from roughly
Santa Barbara up to Juneau,
you have fog banks,
which is because you have cold
water hitting warm air;
it's that cold upwelling water
hitting the warm air that makes
the fog,
which is so characteristic of
the West Coast of the United
States,
and is also characteristic,
by the way,
of the West Coast of Namibia.
There are even some beetles
that live in the desert of
Namibia that are specialized for
catching the fog on their feet.
They stand on their heads and
they put their feet up and they
catch water with their feet,
because it doesn't rain in
Namibia.
Now if we were to look at say
the coast of Oregon,
and we have wind or current
which is coming south;
we're in the Northern
Hemisphere, we're going south.
The Coriolis force is working,
and because we're coming south
we're going to be--
we have less angular momentum
than the earth under our feet,
and therefore it's going to be
diverted out to the west.
That means that there's going
to be a tendency for the
Coriolis force to suck water
offshore.
And the wind or the current
could be coming south,
but the net vector of movement
of surface water will be
deflected off to the right,
by the Coriolis force,
and pulled offshore,
and so you're going to get cold
bottom water,
welling up to the surface and
fertilizing things.
Okay, that's a little bit about
how the climate machine is
working in the ocean.
Now let's take a minute to look
at what it's doing to the biomes
on the surface of the planet,
on the terrestrial part of the
planet.
Ecologists have broken the
planet down into areas that
basically look similar from the
structure of their ecological
communities,
and are thought to be similar
in terms of the general control
of ecological processes.
So you've got ice sheets,
of course.
Then you've got tundra.
In tundra you normally don't
see plants that are taller than,
oh, 10 or 20 centimeters.
You have things like dwarf
birch, lots of moss,
things like that.
Often tundra is overlying
permafrost.
Then you've got the taiga or
the northern coniferous forests,
which stretch across much of
the high latitudes in the
Northern Hemisphere.
You can't really get to these
places in the Southern
Hemisphere.
Okay?
Antarctica is too cold,
and Africa and Australia don't
really go far enough south.
There's a little bit of
replication of this in South
America, but it's mostly a
question there of altitude.
Then you get some forests that
are extremely similar in Eastern
North America,
across Western Europe and into
Central Asia,
and in China and Manchuria,
which is temperate broadleaf
forest.
You get similarities in the
rainforests of the Amazon and
the Congo, and in Southeast
Asia, and in Northern Australia,
and so forth.
There are, in other words,
these large biomes around the
planet that are mainly shaped by
climate.
And I'm just going to touch
quickly on two of them.
One of them is the desert biome.
And one tends to find deserts
at about 30 North and about 30
South.
So, of course,
the Sahara and the Arabian
Desert are at 30 North.
The deserts of Mexico and
Arizona are at about 30 North.
The Chilean and Peruvian
deserts, the Atacama Desert,
are at about 30 South.
The Kalahari and the Namib are
at about 30 South,
and the Great Central Desert of
Australia is about 30 South.
And remember,
this is where you have cold air
falling.
At the equator you have warm
air rising,
and where you have the deserts
you have cold air falling,
and there's very little water
in that cold,
dry air that's falling.
It's quite hot during the day
and it's cold at night.
So, for example,
if you're in the hot desert of
Central Australia,
and it's nightfall,
on a nice clear night the
temperature will go,
say in Fahrenheit,
from 80 or 90 degrees,
down to freezing,
in about two or three hours.
And so Aborigines learn to do
things like all sleep together
in a big bunch.
The wet tropical forests are
about at the equator,
where you have warm air rising;
warm, moisture-laden air is
rising.
There are some interesting
twists on that.
For example,
if you take a packet of air off
the south Atlantic and you blow
it into the Amazon,
the Amazon actually will
transpire the moisture in that
air;
the trees in the Amazon will
transpire it,
so that by the time a packet of
rain,
that started here in the south
Atlantic,
hits the Andes,
it's been rained out three
times.
It's gone back up into the
atmosphere, made a cloud;
gone down into the ground;
gone up into the atmosphere;
rained out, made a cloud.
And it's done that about,
on the average,
three times by the time it hits
the Andes.
So there's some interesting
local stuff going on.
But roughly speaking,
you find the world's greatest
biodiversity near the equator in
these rainforests.
And so if we just take a look
at one of them,
the Corcovado Rainforest in
Costa Rica;
and all of you are eligible to
go on an OTS course to Costa
Rica, and as part of it you'll
probably go to the Corcovado.
Or, if you were lucky enough to
be in Rick Prum's class this
semester,
you got taken by Rick,
over spring break,
to Ecuador, where they logged
450 species of birds in ten
days.
And in that kind of habitat you
are going to run into extremely
high species diversity,
and you're going to see all
kinds of stuff that you just
never run into in the temperate
latitudes.
So I strongly recommend a visit
to one of these places,
if you possibly can.
For a biologist it's pretty
much--this,
and say going over a coral
reef, especially at night,
it's kind of like Christmas,
because every time you turn
around the corner there's
another surprise under the tree
>
and there's something beautiful
and strange that you've never
seen before.
So this is the biological
consequence of a long period of
fairly stable warm,
moist conditions,
which are the ecological
theater that has allowed this
kind of evolutionary play to
take place.
If we look back in time,
there are a couple of things
about say the last--
this is roughly the last
fifty-million years,
from the Eocene up to the
Holocene--
there are a couple of fairly
neat things that have happened
in terms of the global pattern
of climate.
One of them is that if you go
back to Eocene,
when it was really quite warm,
and you had temperate forests
that went right up to the Arctic
Ocean,
you can demonstrate that there
were large trees growing in
Northern Greenland,
at a latitude where it was dark
for nearly six months a year;
it was warm but it was dark.
And that really is a rather
interesting comment on what
trees are capable of;
that you could make a tree that
would live in complete darkness,
not doing anything for six
months, and then turn back on
and become actually quite a tall
forest;
these trees are a meter,
two meters in diameter,
in Northern Greenland.
So that's one kind of thing
that the historical look at
ecology will give you.
But there's another one,
which is really,
I think, important for everyone
on the planet now,
and that is that the Eocene,
Oligocene and Miocene were all
pretty warm;
in fact, they were much warmer
than the earth currently is.
And when you look say at the
distribution of tropical
forests--
which is in green--you can see
that tropical forests covered
really most of the earth for
tens of millions of years;
and compare that to their
distribution now.
We're essentially in an
interglacial in the Pleistocene
right now.
The planet is really much
colder than it has been,
on average.
And you can see those sorts of
trends written in the
distribution of the biomes
across the planet.
And it would be terribly neat
to have a slow motion videotape,
taken from a distant satellite,
over the last 65 million years,
to see this kind of thing going
on.
One would have to be,
of course, a bit patient.
So here are the things I want
you to remember about climate;
organisms and the climate
machine of the planet.
If all you know is the seasonal
pattern of temperatures,
daylight and water
availability,
you can predict a lot about
what you're going to find in
terms of biomass,
in terms of biome;
all that kind of stuff.
I would like you to remember,
out of this lecture and out of
your reading,
how mountains create rain and
rain shadows and hot down-slope
winds.
I'd like you to remember the
pattern of winds and currents,
from the equator to the poles.
I'd like you to remember how
the so-called Coriolis force
works;
how El Niño works,
this wonderful thing of piling
up a meter high mountain of hot
water,
in the Western Pacific,
and then letting it fall back
down;
how ocean currents drive
upwelling;
and why cold,
nutrient-rich water will well
up at the edge of a continent,
or an island;
and how the climate structures
the biomes on the planet.
Okay.